hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hide the fart that's not
weird at all because I'm finally back
home I just got off the plane not an
hour ago I came straight back home and
sat down and recorded something because
I knew that you guys needed something
today and I want to say that Bob's
wedding was fantastic I had a great
birthday with my family I was gonna do a
vlog but then I decided that I really
haven't had enough gameplay videos in
between my last vlog in this one so I'm
kind of gonna roll it into the same one
here as I try to hide the fart and what
would better way to be thankful for my
birthday and you know the sort of stuff
then um to play this game that I played
ages and ages ago that is just the most
ridiculous setup for a game than you've
ever heard I just love the sullen look
at his eyes okay the idea of the game is
that you are supposed to well literally
hide the fart and that's all you do now
you can you can silently leak out some
farts or flatus when oh god I'm getting
mixed up because I'm trying to play here
nope yeah you didn't hear nothing over
there
the world's wedding was just this past
weekend I'm so happy that his wife were
gonna be happy for the rest of his life
playing a farting game and that's what
I'm doing with my life never gonna be
able to get and also I was able to spend
some time with my family and some
friends that I haven't seen in a long
time thank you guys so much for
tolerating the friendship with me being
away in LA I was really good to see
oh thanks my mom and my stepmom of
course being able dang go oh man how am
I supposed to be able to do this I never
was able to get far this game came out
and obviously o4 and you know I've been
playing it on and off since this whole
time period had a bunch of these type of
games that were just completely
ridiculous in their premise but just so
necessary to the world like I cannot
world where this game does not exist
also it's in the description below if
you want to play for yourself it's just
it's this era of things before there was
mainstream sites to play games on
I mean Newgrounds has been around for a
while I don't remember what it's like
this was originally on but god this is
maybe like Japan oh I love he's like the
most devastatingly upset
look you could ever give a human being
like how dare you let loose in front of
me but either way as a game I kind of
roll talking mine talking about my
weekend back home in Cincinnati never
going about and also like combining a
slice into the thing but either way it
was just really good to get back oh to
be home and like see my family again and
see Cincinnati and see you know the
place where I grew up because most of my
conscious life I've never been anywhere
else it's great being out in LA actually
just as soon as I get done with ball
farting my butt off I'm gonna go down
and I'm gonna film another youtubers
react with the venture venture brothers
the fine brothers kind of like The
Venture Brothers if you know what about
you yeah I'm gonna go film and other
youtubers react I don't know what I'm
watching obviously because I'm gonna
react to it but yeah I want to thank
them for the opportunity you guys oh man
I just got so many people to think while
I'm farting by this Japanese man
so thank you guys so much for that is my
life I literally got a plane and rushed
home to play a farting game online that
was made 10 years ago two years ago this
game was made I remember playing this
high school I also drove by my old high
school that was weird
they've done change devastating alright
but either way I'm gonna I'm gonna stop
playing this for now you guys got enough
out of I'm not even concentrating on the
game but just thank you guys so much for
what you guys have done for me it's good
to be back here and you know it's been
great because I get the opportunities
like going over in a film with the fine
brothers for youtubers react um all the
people that have been able to meet the
game grumps CaptainSparklez i've been
able to hang out with you know i did
that a film with jacksFilms the city go
guys were just here last weekend or last
week and i was able to film something
with them and just all the people that
i'm not for me and not remembering right
now but just seriously it's great to be
here as much as I miss home and as much
as I want to be there it's totally okay
that I'm here so just thank you guys so
much for giving me the opportunity and
congratulations Bob everyone please
congratulate Bob on the the best
marriage ever I wish him the best I wish
him only happiness going into life I
know that you know he he deserves to be
happy he is one of my very best friends
and he is so cool and so funny and he
deserves so much more and if you didn't
know he has a YouTube channel so that'll
be down below um and just thank you all
so much for the birthday wishes I'm
still gonna be plowing through birthday
stuff today because I literally was so
busy that I did not have a chance before
so just thank you guys all so much for
everything that you've done I'm gonna
stop thanking you
you guys are awesome so thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
a dinosaur